نحن متفقين على ان لا استطيع لا تعني لا
اريد او انني استطيع الاستطاعه هي مع
الارادات لكن ما تتفضل به ولان الازمه
عالميه هل يمكن ان تكون الحلول فرديه
بمعنى دوله ما تحاول ان تحل المشاكلها
بالاقتراحات التي يمكن ان تقدم دون ان
يكون هناك شراك عالميه في حال هذه الازمه
كونها عالميه ام انه يجب ان تحلل موضوع
جذريا على مستوى العالم
هناك
خمسه تحديات كبار وسوف ترين الى الخمسه
لابد من حلول عالميه وليس حلول فرديه هل
يمكن الحل المشكله المناخيه
والجفاف وقله المياه همم بحلول فرديه يعني
ان احنا في في هناك دراسه تقول تقريبا نصف
سكان البشريه في سنه 2003 2030 سوف تعيش
في تحت نقص كبير في المياه
البحار في العديد من المدن هل يمكن الحل
لهدايا بحلول فرديه مثلا التكنولوجيا
وال- همم
ندفع مثلا كلمه 20 مليون
30 سوف نصل تقريبا 800 دولار استثمارات
يمثل حجمه يعني الانسان جديد تقريبا خمسه
تقريبا
الى حدود لها
وطريقه مراقبتها وقوانينها و و و و الى
ذلك الكلام يمكن ان تحل بطريقه فرديه هل
التغيرات الديمقراطيه الكبرى مثلا الكبرى
كبيره جدا يعني العديد من الدول
الاعمار في سنه 2050 ممكن ستجاوز 55 سنه
في العديد من الدول الكبرى المتطوره
ولكن وفي نفس الوقت في افريقيا في نفس
الفتره ممكن سنصل الى اثنين مليار ونصف
تقريبا 300 مليارات يعني ومعدل الاعمار
اكثر شويه من 20 سنه في سيكون كبير
واضيف الى ذلك هو كان نسبه تباعيه للشراء
اهل المتقدمه في السن يعني اكثر من 65 سنه
سوف تتجاوز 50% في اغلبيه الدول الكبرى
وقد تصل الى 70 و75
ربما تكون اكثر واقعيه وبعيده عن النظريه
في ما يتعلق بمحاولات انقاذ هذا العالم